Days out from the release of the comic book
antihero movie Venom, several news outlets
have obtained some juicy bits of info about
the movie's two post-credits scenes, as well
as one big reveal that would tie into a potential
sequel.
So what does the Tom Hardy-starring, Ruben
Fleischer -directed movie have in store for
viewers?
Grab a snack and check it out.
"So many snacks, so little time."
Now, for those of you who want to walk into
Venom knowing just the basics about what will
go down, we advise you avert your eyes.
If these reports of the post-credits scenes
turn out to be the real deal, then they're
set up to spoil not just what will happen,
but also what definitely won't happen during
the movie.
One more time, for anyone not paying attention:
major spoilers ahead.
According to a report from MCU Cosmic, the
first Venom post-credits scene will see Hardy's
Eddie Brock miraculously maintaining his job
as a journalist, even after transforming into
the people-eating, fang-toothed Venom.
Eddie, hungry to chase down new leads and
cover a fresh story after his wild investigation
of the Life Foundation, reportedly travels
to San Quentin prison to interview a very
special inmate: Cletus Kasady, the serial
killer better known in Marvel Comics as Carnage.
Kasady, as has long been rumored, will in
fact be played by Woody Harrelson, with his
involvement in the movie having been intended
as a secret.
Harrelson will reportedly sport a comics-accurate
red-headed look by donning a ginger wig, lurking
in police custody as a looming menace.
When approached by Eddie Brock, Cletus asks
if he, quote, "wants to hear the carnage"
of the murders he's committed.
You heard right:
"Carnage!"
That's a grade-A, by-the-comic-books tease
for a sequel if we've ever seen one.
So if Venom does even halfway decently at
the box office, it looks like a follow-up
should be coming in hot.
The possibility of Harrelson's involvement
as Carnage has been circulating for months.
After plenty of speculation and uncertainty,
Harrelson finally broke his silence by confirming
his involvement in the movie as well as an
untitled sequel.
Speaking to Collider in May 2018, Harrelson
said,
"I'm in a little fraction of this movie, but
I'll be in the next one, you know?"
Prior to Harrelson's remarks, there was speculation
that Carnage a well-known adversary of both
Venom and Spider-Man would be the main villain
of the movie.
But That Hashtag Show published reports claiming
that Kasady would mostly appear in the post-credits
tease claims which these new reports seem
to confirm.
The outlet cited an unnamed source saying
that Kasady would be in the custody of Ravencroft
Institute founder Dr. Ashley Kafka, a Marvel
Comics character who is highly experienced
in treating criminally insane super-people.
That source also relayed that during Eddie's
talk with Kasady, a part of the Venom symbiote
starts lurching toward him before the screen
cuts to black.
This suggests that somewhere between the first
and second Venom movies, Kasady will obtain
a symbiote of his own, thus becoming the villain
known as Carnage.
If true, this would align with the Marvel
Comics lore, in which Kasady transforms into
the beastly entity after a prison breakout.
As for the second post-credits scene, it reportedly
opens with a scrawl of text, reading, "Meanwhile,
in another Spider-Verse…"
It then launches into a sneak peek at Sony's
upcoming animated feature, Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse, which centers on Miles Morales,
Gwen Stacy, an older Peter Parker, and more
alternate universe Spider-People.
This scene should be arguably less exciting
than the first one, since it isn't directly
related to Venom, but it should nonetheless
put a smile on the faces of Spider-fans.
Still, it's hard not to be a little disappointed.
Post-credits scenes are all basically just
ads for upcoming movies, but this sounds like
it's literally just an advertisement for another
Sony flick, and we can't imagine that will
thrill too many people after sitting through
ten minutes of credits.
But hey!
At least the movie looks pretty great.
So, now that we probably know what the Venom
post-credits scenes will entail, when during
those credits can viewers expect to see them?
According to MCU Cosmic, the first scene is
a more traditional, mid-credits scene that
will start not too long after the movie itself
ends.
The second the Spider-Verse tease is reportedly
at the very end of the credits, serving as
a little bonus for the people who've stuck
around.
Screen Rant - however - is reporting it a
little differently - the additional bits of
footage will actually play out back-to-back.
Until the movie comes out, it's hard to say
for certain, but it sounds like these two
scenes are the only scenes to watch out for.
Of course, at this point, almost two decades
into superhero mania, many audiences are conditioned
not to go anywhere until the staff is sweeping
the theater.
Last-minute surprises are still possible,
so that's the only way to be 100% sure you
saw everything.
But as of now, it's almost certain: Carnage
is coming.
...Eventually.